he's for spend a little time with me
this morning I know it's a beautiful day
outside and everybody's stomachs are
probably rumbling for lunch so
appreciate just been in the hour with me
I want to talk a little about
deconstructing the user interface and
this is an idea that I developed for a
book I wrote a very long time ago but I
still find the idea to be pretty useful
and about every year or two I get an
email from some wandering academic in
South America or Africa or something
that asked me to use the model so I
assume it has a little bit of interest
and still kind of keeps going so I like
to start a lot of these talks with kind
of this informal survey like how many
people in the room have had some sort of
issue with a piece of software something
that frustrated you got you a little
upset got your blood racing a little bit
how many people have had that issue in
the last let's say the last month okay
that's just about everybody a few like
like incredible super girls they don't
have that how many people in the last
week and then how many people so far
today okay not so many people today but
there's still a few I've done this talk
where most the hands are up in the
morning and it's still 9:00 a.m. and so
I like to point to people you know we
talked about software's eating the world
and although the software's not having
indigestion I think we're having a
little bit of trouble with that and I
think a lot of it can be seen sort of in
photos like this and we see a lot of
quotes
you know if froze for a list of all the
ways technology has failed to improve
the quality of life please press 3 we're
stuck with technology when what we
really want is just stuff that works
that's what my favorite the Rage Against
the Machine is really a rage against
badly imagined machines and I think
that's sort of the crux of the problem
and so I've been thinking a lot about
software and how frustrating it seems to
be and I think a lot about what I see
happening in society and the fact that
I've become sort of tech support to the
world and in the genius tool I call my
parents and friends and family and I
suspect many of you are as well and I
just imagine what it must be like to not
be part of the computing environment to
not be you know a superhero when it
comes to using all these devices and to
try to imagine what it must be like to
be a mere mortal just trying to navigate
the app space if you watch people try to
get through an airport and having to
deal with all this different software
you watch people using self-checkout
even using credit card machines you know
and the frustration that you can see
building up
we'll try to navigate all the different
pieces of software that they have to use
in their daily lives and given that I've
been having some time and things to
think about since I've been consulting
and as I mentioned a Michael getting my
kids off to college and listen to a lot
of podcasts I don't know if you guys
have heard of this one this is raw data
it's actually produced here at Stanford
and in season three they sort of began
with this question of how did Silicon
Valley come to be in Silicon Valley and
the season three begins with an episode
about the founding of Stanford called
monument to a dead child and it ends
with an episode of Mark Zuckerberg
testifying between in front of Congress
it kind of winds through the middle
talking about the impact of the
counterculture in Silicon Valley and
particularly the influence of Stewart
Brand and strangely enough LSD and so I
got me thinking about what's the
philosophy of personal computing and one
of the books that they referenced quite
a bit as this one from counterculture
cyber culture and in the introduction
there's this quote which is what
separated the isolated experiments with
small computers from the full-blown
birth the personal computing was the
West Coast realization that computing
was a new medium like books records
movies radios and television and that's
sort of how I think of software I have a
background in film production and so I
tend to think of software as a kind of
appear to movies and one of the most
complex forms of human communication
that there is it's multi-sensory
probably more in some ways more
complicated than movies because it's
interactive and so I really kind of
focused on this idea of computing as a
medium and software as a medium and I
got me thinking about books of course
about music and about movies and one of
the things that all those different
mediums have in common is they have
really well developed critics so people
like Roger Ebert Igor from Pixar's
ratatouille who's actually a food critic
and a fashion critic here and so they
also have like a really well developed
notion of awards you know if you think
about the Academy Awards and all the
different types of awards they have some
of which are around the medium itself
and maybe the context the best animated
Best Foreign Film is sort of the context
of the film there's also a ton of
technical Awards against editing sound
sound design production design costume
design
and then of course acting story all
these different things and if you look
at something like movies
even though movies are constructed from
a lot of different LEGO pieces when
they're making the movie and even us as
viewers we understand that all those
pieces come together to create kind of a
complete whole but we can also have this
conversation about what all those
individual elements are so even though
most of us tend to see software as a
single complete thing we don't really
have a vocabulary for deconstructing it
and really critiquing the individual
elements we tend to talk about
software's we like it we don't like it
it's pretty it's not pretty it's hard to
use it's not hard to use but we don't
have like really a more nuanced
definition or nuanced vocabulary for
talking about the individual elements of
a piece of software and how they might
be interacting and what's interesting or
not interesting about them it's sort of
I call it we can't really see the trees
for the forest and you see this somewhat
in product reviews if you listen to kind
of the critics of software you know the
tech critics they invariably focus on
functionality and if they talk about UI
at all it's usually just in terms of
aesthetics and occasionally they'll see
something about usability but they're
it's very rare that they get really at
the next layer after that and compare
that to like a movie critic that will
get into the weeds about the editing the
pacing the you know the writing the
dialogue the directing there's just a
level of critique that happens in other
mediums
besides software in our tech critics
here I saw Kara was just speaking here I
guess yesterday so David Pogue Kara
Swisher and fahrrad Manju who different
points have all written for the New York
Times if you read their reviews again
it's mostly about functionality and
lately it's mostly about the impact of
tech on society it's very little about
actual UI so the question for today is
like how do we deconstruct a UI so we
can talk about what is good and bad
without referring to the complete
experience without our critique being
random or and different and as someone
who's led a bunch of design critiques at
various companies you know you know that
this is a bit of a problem because every
critique begins with what kind of
feedback do you want you know it's just
a way of the designer trying to set
context so you know what we're talking
about and when they say what kind of
feedback do you want it's usually kind
of at a level of granularity it's not
these are the kind of issues I'm looking
at it's it's rarely like this is where
I'm at at the part where I'm at in the
process and we do have a shared
vocabulary around a type of process
where we tend to go from designing the
structure to designing the wireframes to
designing the visual design that sort of
takes the form like when we talk about
structure we might be talking about site
maps flow maps it usually takes the form
of diagrams and then these things go
from whiteboards you know to
deliverables that look like this you
know if we think about there we go if
you think about what uh wireframes you
know that tends to get more to the page
level so we go from whiteboards that
look like this to paper deliverables
that look something like this and there
was visual design we might start with a
mood board they could look something
like this there's usually not a lot of
intellectual work that goes before the
mood board it really is just sort of
people putting stuff on a board and
seeing what feels right and then a mood
board might eventually turn into a final
visual comp but that's sort of the whole
process right and I think that's okay as
far as it goes but it's just not really
granular enough and although people do
kind of work intuitively in that
sequence they often don't kind of pause
at each moment to really think about the
impact of those decisions when they're
making site maps I don't really think
about how that's gonna flow down to the
rest of the system when they're making
wireframes you see over and over again
people working on wireframes don't
really understand all the visual issues
so we make a bunch of decisions in the
wireframe phase that really impacts and
and in limits what can happen at the
visual level so if we go back to movies
for a second we talked about how we
might be able to deconstruct movies you
know everyone in this room would be able
to think about sort of different ideas
around the story of the movie the actual
production of the movie and sort of the
the final presentation or
post-production and I found this quote
from Walt Disney the story is good the
picture may be good but if the story is
weak good color music and animation
cannot save it and do I think what's
interesting here is he's calling out
color music animation he's calling out
discrete elements of the movie and how
they said how they can or can't support
the overall movie experience it even as
viewers of movies even as people who
aren't involved in moviemaking
professionally probably most of you in
the room could still talk about movies
in terms of the genre the characters the
plot cinematography production design
acting you'd have some conscious idea of
all of those things and you probably
have opinions about those things and you
would have certain movies that you
thought were
less interesting in those particular
aspects so the thing is like design now
is a group project right we don't really
have a vocabulary for talking about this
stuff and I love this African proverb
use this a lot if you want to go fast go
alone if you want to go far go together
we're living in a world where we want to
go far and so we have to find ways of
working dynamically as teams which again
means we need some sort of shared
vocabulary and so a shared model would
give us the right focus at the right
time it would help us solve a UI problem
in the most efficient sequence it would
help us improve pattern recognition and
it would streamline a lot of
communication I kind of compare the my
model a little bit to sentence
diagramming these are probably way too
small to read it's not that writers
necessarily think in terms of sin it's
diagrams but there's a way there's a
grammar that we all share where we can
deconstruct the sentence to better
understand what is and isn't working and
how they're supposed to be fit together
to communicate properly so I started
thinking about like what UI models have
already been proposed you know if we
look at the webbie's compare that to the
Oscars they do have some technical
things that they call out best
navigation structure best user
experience but I don't really know what
best user experience means that's is
that like best picture like I don't
really I don't really know that one best
navigation structure I kind of get and
then the rest of it is you know it's a
lot of technical things it's some of its
a lot of the webbie's actually around
the context to use so it's the best
marketing piece it's the best corporate
piece things like that so this is kind
of one model for how we might think
about UI elements another one it's kind
of these UI principles this is from
usability gov and this is all pretty you
know bread-and-butter stuff keep the
interface simple I've never heard
anybody advocate for making the
interface more complicated so I don't
really know if that's been a
particularly useful thing and in design
critiques nobody's really arguing
against consistency or purposefulness
and page layout I mean these are all
nice things to keep in mind but they're
not really ways of facilitating a
discussion because nobody's going to
take the opposite side of the argument
Jesse James Garrett got a while back I
think this is from 2000 he proposed a
pretty interesting model where he talked
about
the web is a software interface and he
did sort of start down here with side
objectives and user needs but he just
kind of gets interaction design and
information architecture it kind of just
all gets blurred up there at the top
again kind of falling this structure
behavior presentation stuff so it's a
it's an interesting model but I don't
think it's granular enough or focused
enough just on UI itself so maybe I'm
missing some models maybe there's some
other things out there that have been
proposed that I haven't seen but I still
kind of go back to what are the all the
elements of UI and how can we talk about
it in more granular terms so here's what
I'm thinking as I mentioned I do kind of
like the idea that the structure then
there's behavior then there's
presentation but I think within
structure there's a little bit more
nuance there between the conceptual
model the task flow of the app and the
organizational model the interesting
thing about the structure tiers it's the
most abstract you'll never hear users
really talk about this nobody's gonna
sit in a usability test and talk about
how they were confused by the conceptual
model but if they don't get the
conceptual model they're gonna be
confused throughout the whole test um
it's also something that you see
practitioners very rarely sit and pause
and really think about and compare the
trade-offs I haven't been in a lot of
meetings where people had three or four
or five different ideas for the
information architecture first night or
three or four different ideas about the
task flow for a particular operation or
even completely different approaches to
what the product could be at a
conceptual level usually there's just an
intuition they get with that one thing
and move forward even though it has
enormous consequences for the rest of
the design process after the structure
area then we have behavior so again we
talked about this is kind of pure
interaction design there's really
different sub elements here that's what
I call viewing and navigation editing
and manipulation and then user
assistants and I'm gonna go through each
one of these layers in a lot more detail
which is the really the majority of the
talk so we'll kind of get into the weeds
on each one of these and finally the
presentation layer this is the piece
that most people would think about when
they think about design it's simply what
the design looks like it's the the
visual kind of a static piece but even
there there's the layout of the of the
page which users wouldn't necessarily
consciously think about but it has a big
impact on their understanding of what
the app is about and how to use it and
then course style which is typography
and color and what people typically
think of when they think of designers
with
glasses and cool ties and all that sort
of stuff and then text so that's the
copy that appears in the design which is
a piece that I that you just see ignored
over and over and over again nobody
really wants to take ownership for the
copy you see a few companies starting to
hire copywriters but it's still pretty
rare that you'll see a dedicated
copywriter working on UI copy as opposed
to marketing copy so I want to use that
model sort of as a roadmap as we go
through each one of these different
layers and I want to show you examples
from products that I think are doing
some interesting sometimes really
interesting good stuff and sometimes
maybe not so great stuff and each one of
those layers so you start to understand
more how when I'm doing a creative
review how I break things down and pick
out particular elements I want to talk
to the designer about so you know it
turns out this quotes attributed to a
lot of people but I'm gonna atribute it
to Edward Tufte
design it's clear thinking Meade made
visible and I think that really comes
through the most and the structural
elements you know you're really thinking
clearly about what the product is and
what it could be and how that gets
manifest and/or information architecture
or the conceptual model etc conceptual
model is the most fundamental aspect of
the interface it relates the UI to the
outside world by allowing users
associated something new the software
was something that they've experienced
in the physical world it helps them
scramble up the learning curve of
novelty and make accurate predictions
about the system's behavior you know
kind of answers the basic question what
is this thing now let's talk about like
Microsoft Word is essentially a
typewriter and people can kind of relate
it to a typewriter that's a really fancy
typewriter but it's essentially a
typewriter and I'm yet to see any other
I'm yet to see any software that didn't
in some ways yeah do we start making it
about electronic things I think so I'm
making this new dark matter I'm going to
be about it like Microsoft Word
you know some thing that's gone in the
past is that why do or do we still think
of it as tying it to some other object I
I think of users if they can in the
consumer space unless you want them to
have to learn a whole lot of new stuff
it's gonna be very hard for them to just
step into a new piece of consumer
software if they don't have some
reference I think that's mostly physical
reference references but you're you know
I get your point
I wonder if too many young adults
wouldn't know what a typewriter is they
might not have direct experience using
one but I don't know if the like I don't
know if you have to tie it to something
that they're actively using day in and
day out may not many of us use
spreadsheets on a printed piece of paper
but we understand column their data and
we can use that concept to leverage into
a spreadsheet processor electronic you
still answer the question like what is
this thing and when they first open it
up I think they have trouble they need
some way of orienting towards it and
I've seen apps like most recently that
was play with an app called agenda which
is trying to do some interesting stuff
related to tying your to-do items and
notes into your calendar but I was
completely flummoxed and I show
something from air table later but but
you know agenda spends a lot of time
upfront trying to train you as to what
the product is and like I just think you
probably so many people drop off of that
you know Pinterest haven't worked there
they have this trouble with the
conceptual model like people don't
actually know what Pinterest is and even
if you went to the company today and
asked them to describe Pinterest they
would struggle with that most people
keep coming back to this scrap booking
thing which is not really how they want
it to think about the company internally
in one that's doing something really
interesting in the conceptual model
space is a bit icky I don't know how
many of you guys know habiddig a
laviticus takes the idea of gamification
in a completely different direction when
we talk about gamification we often talk
about kind of bolting
game-type devices like awards and
competitions on to an existing problem
space like losing weight or something
habiddig is interesting to me because it
flips that model around it actually
starts with the idea of a game and then
it puts the to-do-list habit management
daily trackers on side of it so this is
sort of the startup screens but this is
sort of the you know the bulk of abetik
a-- so here you see here's some habits
you know always trying to maintain
calories try to not use the phone only
eat for nine hours a day here's the
stuff I have to do there's all my
Stanford presentation stuff which this
is probably the most difficult one to do
these are different things that I'm
trying to do every day and then you'll
see up at the top you know I'm this
character Bob to procrastinate and I'm
level 100 into healer you know and you
can see my health my experience my mana
scores like that's actually the thing
that I'm managing in this app like I
actually relate to it as a game so I'm
trying to keep my character alive and
I'll do I'll go way out of my way to
finish as much stuff as possible to keep
my character from dying and dropping
back a level in addition I can take my
character and I can joy I can as I get
gold I can buy different things I can
actually go on quests with friends where
we're as a team we're getting points as
we collectively get our stuff done and
that gives us access to go and capture
different types of animals and stuff and
it's you know it's all maybe at some
level it's kind of goofy but for me it's
actually pretty motivating and fun and
from it again from a conceptual
perspective I thought this was really
fascinating that they took what's
essentially a habit tracking to-do list
and they just flipped the whole thing
around and they started with a game a
role-playing game as the conceptual
model and then they put these other
features on top of it another one to
look at is a robot you guys seen well
bot I think a lot of the robot
technology's done here so so whoa bot is
basically a cognitive behavioral
therapist app so cognitive behavioral
therapy app so if you guys don't know
CBT it's a really standardized and I
don't want to underrepresented
complexity of CBT but CBT is a method of
therapy to help people break out of kind
of known mental patterns like
all-or-nothing thinking and a lot of CBT
can be applied in a fairly formulaic way
so you see a lot of apps
designed specifically to help administer
caught into behavioral therapy most of
those apps things like mood notes
they're actually they perform as logs
and so you kind of fill out a survey and
then it and then it'll point you to kind
of an issue that it thinks you might
want to learn more about robots
different it's actually an AI chat bot
so it responds to what your to what
you're saying
I think the stat was in the first day
that whoa bot went live it saw there was
something like fifteen twenty thousand
people that visited it so there was one
day it visited way more helped way more
people than a single therapist could do
in an entire career so there's the
startup screens for whoa bot and then
this is what it's like when you're
actually in it so what whoa bot did is
it took CB Tina turned it into a
conversation which is probably the right
conceptual model for a therapy
relationship although nobody else had
done that before they'd all done sort of
this again sort of journaling logging
type models so here it says it'll you
know it'll check in with you at the
start of each conversational ask how
you're doing and then you it gives you
different options if you want to talk
about your mood and how you're doing and
eventually what it'll do is try to point
you into different types of videos to
help you understand what's going on with
a particular mode of thinking again
here's sort of the all-or-nothing so get
an interesting conceptual model you know
if you're gonna go do something on
therapy to think oh it should be a
conversation but how many you know how
many apps doing therapy actually start
with a conversation which again probably
is the right conceptual model with other
questions or you guys just feel free to
interrupt me as I go along here so task
flow that's how users move through the
through the application concerned with
the manner and the user complete
specific operations interesting thing
about the task flow is it's really
dependent on the type of computing
device they're using so the task flow
you might see on a on a on a mobile
device is different from what you might
see on a kiosk is different from what
you might want it's what you might see
in a desktop app because the way you
select objects and manipulate them can
vary a lot based on those environments
so I talked about task flows the three
things that I talked about it's what I
call hubs wizards and guides and I'll go
through a couple of these quickly so
this is what a wizard you guys probably
all know Wizards from Microsoft
Microsoft Windows I think was the one
that first used the language and this is
some sort of flow where there's actually
some dependency as you go from step to
step
checkout is a common example on on
mobile or checkouts a common example
period so here we start with the cart
from this is from the biking store Rafah
where they have very expensive biking
clothes that are awesome but painfully
expensive so the choices that you make
here affect what you make with shipping
address the shipping address affects the
kinds of shipping methods they can offer
you and then all this stuff affects your
final price so they don't ask you for
your payment stuff till the end so
there's a pendency as you move through
the through the phases we saw this what
I was working at Apple on some of the
software they used in retail if you look
at their so if their checkout devices
that the that the that the staff uses
you know it's just a whole sequence of
Wizards is somebody like buying a Mac is
somebody buying an iPhone is somebody
activating a somebody returning a device
they're all just these very dependent
wizards different model is a hub this is
where you have kind of a single central
place that sometimes reveals a status
and sometimes it doesn't and you kind of
shoot off you go and you fix one thing
and you come back you go off and fix one
thing you come back you see it in
settings is a really obvious place so
here from iOS
camera which this one's from and this is
from another habit tracking app so again
instead of having like a linear sequence
you have a single location you're kind
of going off and editing one thing and
then bouncing back so that's what I
would call this is what I call a hub
previous thing would be a wizard and
then what I call a guide is where you go
through the wizard to start with and
then you end up in a hub so a good
example there would be an iPhone startup
screen so when you first unbox an iPhone
it takes you through a sequence of steps
where it's asking about connecting to
your network it's asking your username
your password for iCloud ask you all
these things that it used pre configure
all your settings it's also common on a
startup or startup experiences for
things like Facebook most of the
questions they ask you at the beginning
you're gonna come back to and you can
answer them again later I don't know if
there's a lot of different ways that
people interact with with how you move
through an app these are the two most
common ones that I've seen three most
common ones I've seen but I don't know
how you know these things are not
something that people
to talk about in the design process they
sort of just Intuit their way into this
is how it's going to work usually
because a technical requirement
organizational model is what we might
also call the information architecture
describes how the system's content
functionality of ordered and categorized
so it includes both the classification
scheme and then our things gonna be
hierarchically displayed or just sort of
a big long index and for this you know
one of the things that I like to talk
about when I talk about the power of ia
so I like to talk about zoos so if you
go to the San Francisco Zoo it's sort of
interesting because they have multiple
ways of representing how you might think
about nature and there's actually some
really interesting and powerful sort of
philosophical underpinnings to this idea
so if you if you go to the zoo they have
this bear environment so you go to the
bear grotto and you see bears from
around the world all represented
together they also have the they have
the pachyderm house which is kind of
weird and then they have like this cat
thing so there's there's places in the
zoo where they're talking about animals
taxonomically organized which is a
really ancient idea that older idea
that's really something that the
Victorians came up with when they first
started bringing zoos into England and
they sort of thought about collecting
animals like they were collecting a
bunch of postage stamps right they kind
of took the animals completely out of
the national context and they just
showed all the cats together they shot
all the Bears together they showed only
you know all the pachyderms together
it's really very different model from
nature of nature than what they're
trying to do up here in African savanna
or over there in the outback trail or
South America or like there they're
starting to get into this more
comprehensive view of nature as to how
the animals live together into a single
environment they're trying to use the
zoo to represent what you might see in
the wild and this exhibit here the
African savannah is actually the only
exhibit in the zoo where you see
multiple species actually interacting
together as they would in nature so when
I think about information architecture I
think about those kinds of those kinds
of issues there's actually something
really inherently meaningful about how
you divide up the system and what things
are going to talk about what nouns and
classifications are going to identify
particularly in the tray and
mobile app's particularly in those five
icons that appear at the bottom so if we
look at these apps you know you can
start to get some sense of what the apps
are about just by looking at the tray
you would guess that this probably has
something to do with flying that's
probably has something to do with trains
this one's a little bit harder to
identify part because there's no labels
and also you're not really referring to
any objects here these are all mostly
operations and then this one you might
be able to quickly identify as Airbnb
because you've got trips there
this one's Disneyland when we were
working on the Apple Store app the
initial release of the Apple Store app
you know I had this insight that the you
know the way to start and get into the
design process where we were trying to
bring together the online store in
retail for the first time was to try to
decide exactly what these five objects
were gonna be in the tray and when I
looked at most apps at the time they
tended to be nouns and those nouns
determined and communicated to the user
what objects were available in the
system and so we just let a really
simple design exercise I kind of
brainstormed maybe 20 or 30 different
objects and it could be some pretty
obvious like cart featured stores things
like that wrote them down on big cards
and then we got the executive team
together and we literally just kind of
did a card sorting exercise on the board
we just had stuff pinned up with magnets
and we went through until the two VPS
for the SVP for retail and the VP for
the online store until their teams and
then it kind of settled like yep those
are the five that's what we're gonna
launch with and that's still basically
what the product has today again it's
some companies they just don't really
think hard about what those things
should be and it ends up being sometimes
you see it as part of a representation
of the company's org structure or maybe
parts of the technology they don't
really think carefully about what those
different objects could be so if we go
to kinds of viewing and navigation stuff
this has to do with where you're making
changes to where the user is
manipulating the environment so that
they can see the the data in a different
way but they're not making permanent
changes they're not really they're not
altering something in the database
they're altering how they are looking at
the information what they're seeing this
is an example this is what I used when I
was with my
his class as a studio instructor the
project we had for the team or for the
class was to try to do faceted browsing
they everybody kind of went into this
thinking it would be a really simple UI
problem it turns out to be an incredibly
complicated UI problem and still one
that I think is fairly unsolved this is
from the Apple Store app so you're here
looking at cases and protection you say
you want to filter and then you get sort
of this much longer list this is only
some of the stuff it actually goes like
way down here through the floor and
about ten ten stories below and then
what happens is you start to click on
different objects like here you've
clicked on cases and covers and then
you'll see that if you click cases and
covers then armbands and hard cells no
longer apply but you could still pick
those other ones those other four and
then as soon as you pick cases and
covers all the iPad compare I'm sorry
it's here that clicked cases and covered
so they've clicked iPhone access and
then it goes through that starts
disabled different options it doesn't
really tell me how many how many
products I can see now doesn't really
give me any idea of what those products
are but it it's allowing me to to select
the qualities I care about and it
actually is doing something intelligent
so I don't accidentally navigate myself
into zero found set so I do all those
things and then eventually having gone
all the way down the list here then I
have to navigate back up to the top and
hit done and now I see this is my set of
products again there wasn't a lot of
feedback as I was going along but I got
to express exactly the kind of thing I
was looking for it's a pretty
complicated UI and it's it's when you're
using it it's actually pretty intrusive
and pretty out of sync with the rest of
the app this is the same kind of UI but
from Amazon so Amazon's not early is
visually attractive but interactively
it's kind of interesting you hit the
filter button up there then you drop
down this ridiculously long list in this
particular case I for some reason I had
to go and pick what the department I
wanted and I wanted like cases or
something I guess basic cases and what
they're doing is they're updating the
the results behind me so that's actually
pretty useful I get to see products that
are meaningful for the kinds of thing I
was looking for sort of strangely
because it's Amazon when I started I had
a hundred thousand possibilities and
after hitting a couple of filters I've
narrowed it down to fifty thousand and
then now I only have ten
in cases to look through so again a
pretty wonky UI you know when I'm
shopping for an iPhone case and then
this is Airbnb again Airbnb doesn't it
kind of gives you this update about how
many things that you found but it's not
really it's not really relying that to
in a useful way
this list is also just ridiculously long
and how the dependencies work is really
really goofy but these are really
commonly used you eyes very very
complicated again I'm just kind of
consider this whole thing faceted
browsing still to be an unsolved problem
for a lot of these mobile apps but
specifically if we were looking that
happened doing a critique we could talk
about you know this affects our viewing
and navigation this is now going to
affect some users data so you don't have
the same sort of error state issues and
being able to undo options that you'd
have other stuff editing a manipulation
this is when you're actually getting in
and changing underlying data so this is
from the LinkedIn profile and a very old
picture of me what I which I keep using
so people can't tell how old I am
a lot of data to deal with here the
keyboard keeps coming up and down it's
sort of weird how you you hit add new
education it takes you to another forum
you get to save that and then you have
to come back and save on top of this one
as well so a little bit of a weird
sequencing here I kind of wish they had
done just a more traditional hub where
you saw your profile and then you had to
go off and edit things one by one you
kind of felt more like you were building
it this is a weight loss app called
think called lose it I guess it's a
calorie tracker called lose it and it
only results in weight loss if you
actually do the right things um you know
probably the biggest issue for there you
are one of the biggest issue is how you
input your data so you know how you add
food it comes in here you hit you say
you want to add something for lunch then
you can do a search or you can actually
pick from previous meals if these
controls you keep having to go up to the
upper right hand corner to go to the
next step and then you come back but
they've actually got the the whole
process of editing here pretty tight for
having how you change how you along a
particular meal and there's not a lot of
situations we can get into error
conditions
I actually look at this and think
they've done the editing piece really
well and then these are just different
screens of different ways to different
editing screens again from iOS from the
settings area where you see some
controls directly on the screen some you
have to go off to another page to edit
this is from asana I'm not exactly sure
what to do with this page so if I was
working with that team I'd kind of focus
a lot on how you manage tasks in the Sun
I'm just really confused by the page in
general I thought this was an initiative
a to take different options instead of
just having a particular a single list
where you hit a bunch of checkboxes
which is an interesting way because
these things as you change the as you
click when they move off and you do
stuff that came from the beats UI early
on when you were picking different
musical genres and then this is from the
app agenda again sort of an editing
screen just really complicated like a
lot of stuff going on and user
assistance is the parts of the app that
talk that are communicating at the user
activity status includes a lot of
training guides it's something that
designers don't often think about
consciously there might be particular
efforts to go design some sort of online
help system or some things like that but
there's not our tutorials onboarding
system stuff like that but they don't
necessarily bake this into their overall
UI process there's not usually a team
dedicated to this I think games do a lot
of onboarding training better than most
this is from cut the rope and the way
they kind of slowly step you into all
the different things that the app can do
after like three or four screens which
then they tell you what to do and then
you actually do it in the app they don't
take you to a different place to do it
so you actually feel like you're
learning the skill as you go along
so for cut the rope Angry Birds a bunch
of games are able to do this when you
get to the software side it gets a
little trickier this this is actually
kind of the equivalent to what I just
showed and cut the rope this is what you
see from air table and air table
obviously has a huge problem of
educating us to how to use the app and
what was sort of strange about going
through this is even though they try to
show you this small version of the
excuse me this fault small version of
the app you feel like you're just
looking at static screens and you should
be able to just like tap on the screen
and go to the next one you feel like it
should just be so
of a normal next next next type thing
you actually have to tap where they put
the little blue button so they're sort
of in this weird spot where they kind of
feel like you're manipulating the UI but
not really and then these are a variety
of user assistance elements related to
air validation so again back to LinkedIn
and sort of this completely useless air
thing up there there are some invalid
fields okay not quite sure what to do
with that this is a little bit better
errors were found with the address you
provided please check the errors below
and resubmit your address there give me
a little bit of follow on and they do
tell me which fields are off and then
here you have a field validation right
up against the the form element so
that's much more useful and then this is
actually one of the more interesting
things I just noticed this on a flight
from a couple of weeks ago my gate
changed this is a this is a pass from
the wallet a boarding pass from Apple
wallet and when I open the past they
actually animated that little circle
drawing in and it's one of the most
interesting kind of user assistance
things I've seen in a long time where
they really drew your attention in a
really simple way this probably goes
back to some technology that's been at
Apple for a long time or they used to
have Bubble help and have headways where
they could actually circle UI elements
which again I think it's kind of an
interesting alternative and much more
meaningful to the user that's sort of
the air table approach where they're
taking you through this kind of
disembodied UI experience it's sort of
like the product but it's not actually
the product so if you can give people
help on the product itself that seems to
be more useful this is one of my
favorite quotes particularly in the
realm of we start talked about visual
design it's a great quote mostly because
you have to know who Ansel Adams is but
with visual design you know it's easy in
certain does in certain environments
easy for designers to do what I call
Photoshop pyrotechnics and kind of come
in and press ever impress everybody cuz
it looks really pretty but they haven't
really done all the thinking about the
other layers below so for me it was
always frustrating to go into design
reviews where things looked great but
the thinking was really poor and so I
kind of say that as a caveat against
don't get too sucked into how beautiful
it is when you're looking at just a UI
and you're not thinking about the
previous layers
so we talk about layout you know layouts
how the elements are arranged on the
page there's actually not that many
different layout styles you see on
mobile mostly because the way people
have two limitations around scrolling
what I think's interesting about where
layouts evolved is when you think about
a particular type of application the
layout they use actually really ties
down to the conceptual model and there's
actually very little variation within a
particular class of app so the very
little variation around what kind of
layout makes sense and how it
communicates to the user that that's
what this app is about so these are all
travel apps you see VRBO and Airbnb are
almost identical in terms of their
layout and then here when we get into
sorry I camera which one this one is
this is from the SPG site again
virtually identical you kind of
immediately know these are travel apps
in part because of the photography but
also in park is the way that they're
kind of bucketed with the big giants
travel buckets one after another these
are newspaper sites again you sort of
see these big chunks one after another
there's just very little variation in
layout across newspapers and across
magazines and even across video there's
just a lot of similarity and how they
represent how videos themselves are
represented and how they're grouped
together to communicate that there's a
larger catalogue here this from Fandango
Apple and then Netflix and Amazon and
then the one that's sort of a weird
weird outlier here is Hulu so when I get
to Hulu I'm actually always a little
confused because it seems so different
from the other apps the layout for the
startup experience is they sort of just
show you one thing and then they have
much lower density as you go through
their catalogue which makes me think
there's a lot less stuff on Hulu so I'm
not exactly sure why they went for this
layout instead of using a more
traditional video catalog layout I don't
know I'm always a little confused by who
also cuz the way they do highlights
there's a little weird so if you see TV
shows and the highlights above it's
actually a really kind of non-standard
thing highlights usually from I guess
from link underlines usually appear
below the thing that's being selected so
particularly when you start up Hulu and
you've got the list of accounts on the
left-hand side
it's very confusing as to which one
selected at any given time because of
where they're placing the highlight and
I wanted to point out this screen in
particular because really the big
difference between these two screens is
to the user is the layout here you've
kind of got a catalog where things are
listed in this boxy way and then here
you've got a list but it actually plays
in perfectly to like the fact that
you're looking at featured where there's
not a particular specific order and then
here you're looking at charts where you
need to be able to show that there's a
specific forced rank order so just with
the layout you're really quickly
communicating to the user that the order
in the sequence matters as I talked to
the class to Michael's class a couple
years ago we were talking about layout I
went through some of the gestalt
principles of layout that sometimes
designers use consciously and sometimes
they don't
the idea of proximity similarity closure
and continuity and you see those
operating and sorry on the layout layer
and then style again is the piece that
most people think about this is
typography color I get to quote myself
here because it's the only quote I have
that gets picked up on the internet but
somehow this one's made it way made its
way into some of the design quote
catalogs like all forms of design visual
designs about problem solving not about
personal preference or a supported
opinion I've had many fights with
graphic designers about that idea but I
do think when somebody's proposing a
particular particular visual design you
kind of have to push back and ask them
why why is it that call or why is that
that type why aren't those sizes what
are they trying to communicate because
all those elements to communicate
something and they need to be
communicating and harmony with what the
product is about this is from headspace
this kind of interesting headspace is a
meditation app most of you probably know
headspace I mean it's an interesting
model of meditation right because it
seems to be the whole thing here's about
being happy and being serene and this
sort of this whole cartoon look and it
comes through in every element of the
design they're actually kind of really
well known for this particular visual
design and they're they're their
animations which also are kind of very
cartoony it's a really different model
visually than this which is a another
meditation app this is waking up by
Harris that to apps to essentially the
same thing but just to the visual design
they're communicating a really different
philosophy of meditation have you
actually used Sam's stuff it's a little
bit more serious it's it's not quite so
cartoony and it's he has a very
different style in this audio narration
and Andy does on headspace I suppose you
could look at these things and you could
talk about which ones do I like which
ones do I not like I think my point is
more that you need to say well what are
these things actually communicating you
know did they really mean headspace to
be this cartoony thing when they started
or they just kind of fall in love with
that design early on because one of the
things you know with you notice with
headspace is you kind of start to age
out of it after a while you know use it
for about a year or so and then you
start thinking I've kind of grown out of
that cartoony phase I want something
that's a little bit more serious now and
then the last layer is this text and
copy piece so it includes all the copy
ins inside the app including form labels
names of input navigational controls
messages alerts these are three
different screens from three different
financial service companies this is
American Express Bank of America and
chase hey they and they're just talking
to me really different ways to the text
you know American Express consistent
with their idea of membership they're
starting with my name they're kind of
putting my name up there really big it
seems like they know me they're talking
about how long they've been in a
relationship with me you know it really
underscores this whole whole messaging
piece and then their labels here are
actually pretty straightforward and
simple there's not really too many verbs
in here so it's really straightforward
these are the these are the noun
elements this is a Bank of America where
they try you know try asking Ericka it
seems a little soft try asking Eric
they're like what does what does that
mean he's known and who the hell is
Erica
turns out Eric is their chat bot but is
it try cuz Erica doesn't actually work
that well or is it is it try like maybe
Erica can help you and then they have
this you know kind of more complicated
language around open a new account order
check manage card settings manage card
settings is just a different way of
saying it in card management and these
all these strings end up being much
longer and then here's Chase who doesn't
really seem to know who I am and doesn't
really seem to care too much there's
really nothing here
even indicates to me that I'm in chase
it's you know I mean I'm using the app
so they probably presume that I know
that but it seems like it'd be pretty
easy for them to have some labeling
again they're sort of mixing nouns and
verbs as well so kind of three different
models of how the company thinks about
me just communicated through words this
is actually from the chase app I just
had to bring this out for fun
this is if I want to change my language
from English to Spanish or something and
so they've got a whole bunch of language
up there choose the language you would
like us to use when we talk to you and
then parenthetically for example on the
phone and one of our branches are in
some of the alerts and some of the
alerts and notifications we send you
it's like that's a lot for one it's a
lot of text and it's really soft and
really unclear and then they have this
this help alert keep in mind like okay I
don't keep what in mind and then I can
say huh you know then I can show the
details and then there's this whole
thing we can always help you with all of
our products in English kind of more
parenthetical stuff and when you change
your preferred language it doesn't
affect your account settings including
your statements it's just a lot of stuff
to take in and then my favorite part of
the features when I change it to Spanish
everything's still in English like wow
okay I wanted to talk in Spanish but I
guess I can't and then also it's just
sort of a weird NIT is when you change
it to a different language this text
right here changes and so the length of
that text changes and so these buttons
actually end up bouncing around well
just a little visually jarring and then
this is kind of everybody's favorite the
404 pages actually didn't leave off the
worst one which was just like a server
error screen so this is from United this
is actually these are all off websites
rather than app so it's actually pretty
rare to get into a 404 page in that app
but you know for the website it's not
that uncommon so you know it's actually
at least taken ownership of the problem
you know we apologized but the whole
page is pretty horked and broken so they
obviously haven't spent too much time
thinking about this and the thing with
alerts is by the time the user gets to
an alert they're already kind of in a
animated flustered state something's
gone wrong you know it's the time when
you actually want to be the most
thoughtful and the most helpful to them
and kind of talk to them the nicest way
possible and so I think it's the place
to kind of put your best foot forward
even though it's the part of the
experience that kind of everybody puts
at the very end intends to forget about
New York time zones the fact that Paige
wasn't found they're apologetic and then
they give you some stuff to go look at
which is useful this is from Adobe I'm
not quite sure what I say unchartered
waters I'm not sure what waters has to
do with with Adobe maybe its eyes into
what the pictures are here but at least
they give you a couple other places to
go and then Google just sort of like
drops in the middle of nowhere it's you
know 404 I mean you know these to refer
to 404 errors I don't know if mere
mortals know what a 404 error is and
then Google like that's all we know it
seems like a pretty obvious place for
them to put a search box so at least you
could continue but they just kind of
drop you off and 404 that that's that's
know and then this is a company I think
is actually spending some time thinking
about the text this is a bonobos the the
clothing store outfitting made easy you
never have to worry about what the where
again in the morning we'll help you
decide and save you time for eating
breakfast least you know it's kind of
fun and responsive the fact that you're
trying to live through your day all this
different stuff about like save dives
for when and not if they do a nice job
of explaining with the what the options
gonna mean will notify you but only
about things you care about you know so
it's a nice way of saying we're not
gonna spam you with a whole bunch of
silly notifications and then this was
kind of interesting if you abandon their
cart you know you left something your
cart it's rolling away it took me a
second to realize they've been a
physical cart and it was rolling into
the parking lot but it was sort of cute
instead of you know just something silly
but you left your cart don't you want to
come back and finish the purchase that
you purposely abandoned and probably
meant to so bonobos is one of those
companies you look at they obviously
have a copywriter sitting and thinking
about this stuff and many many app
companies don't so what's that all mean
where's the beef so we go back to the
model I just described earlier those are
the different layers we went through and
if I was doing a design review how I
would think about the different elements
of the UI the piece that I wanted to
call out here is you know when I when I
when I thought about this model the
impact on the
the elements that the users aware of
kind of run in counter to what you would
think like the stuff they're most aware
of there's all this stuff out here in
the presentation layer like if you were
to go to talk to them in a user study
they might talk about how the UI was was
ugly or they didn't understand some of
the text they would never consciously
talk about the navigation scheme even
some of the things related to viewing
whatnot all these lower levels that
actually have an enormous impact on
whether or not they can use the product
they would never know how to talk about
that consciously kind of impact on
usability so these these things run
counter the stuff that they're most
aware of probably has the lowest impact
on usability and then fortuitously for
us the stuff that they talk about the
most that has the lowest impact on
usability there's also the easiest stuff
to change familiar with focus on the
presentation layer and therefore you
know junior designer doesn't spend as
much time on those other things they
they know their tool and so they're like
hey I'll get it in sketch write down and
I'll start doing presentation layer
stuff instead of focusing on fear I'll
throw a conceptual model list and the
right class pose and so you know is it
in some way besides training and
education that the tools that they're
used to are the ones that keep them the
haints of everything nail if you have a
hammer kind of problem I think part of
us the tools and they that it feels
productive like when you're sitting and
producing comps it feels productive and
it's what people in the company expect
to see from you you know if you come
back with a diagram about how to think
about the product differently like
engineering and executive management
they're not really gonna know how to
engage in that I was able to do some of
that when I was working on the online
store because we had a group that had
been kind of churning on the visual
design piece for a long time and because
the company afforded us at the time I
was able to take a step back and say
okay at the homepage for the online
store what's that about and we had like
a really clear hierarchy of the users
and it was really specific the users
need to be able to locate hero products
they need to be aware of all the
different things we sell and then they
need to understand all the reasons they
should buy on the
online store and that design was like
really clearly structured against that
but I think it's because the company
again could afford us time and
understood the importance of that that
that exercise I don't know if it's so
much that designers jump into the tools
because it's the only thing they know to
do I think it's just an expectation you
know you don't have too many it's a
thing people see yeah I mean you come to
the meeting they want to be able to see
the comps and talk about the comps and
it and you know they'll rathole really
quickly on on visual aspects with people
just sort of accepting the underlying
you know like like we all kind of accept
that self-checkout it's safe way treat
you like a criminal you know it's it's
the thing exists and that's just how it
is
nobody really I don't think anybody
anybody designing that self checkout
system never step back and said how do
we how do we change the model this so it
feels more like a customer facing
experience and more like a helpful a
helpful kiosk rather than trying to make
you function as an employee for us
all that said I just wanted to point out
that you guys also like this big giant
balance of things um it does proceed
from foundational to supporting so it's
not like you could necessarily go
through the the design process kind of
each one of those layers one at a time
they all have to interact with each
other but there as you get to again
things in the presentation layer you
need to be keeping in mind the lower
levels and how that stuff helps to
support or distract from the lower
levels and if I could leave you with
anything I one of the things that really
stood out for me about my career is that
it turns out that I've worked on
products that have been used by over a
billion people which is pretty
astonishing number actually have quite a
few colleagues who have worked on
products to touch that many people the
weird thing is we've never seen any of
them you know it's really rare that you
see somebody using your work in the wild
which is really different from almost
any other medium you know musicians have
concerts movie stars get recognized in
public you know even authors have have
readings and stuff but software
designers like we're all like super
anonymous which is has some real
downsides for the industry it also means
it's really easy to forget the impact of
the decisions you're making and how many
people are gonna be affected downstream
so the decisions you make around you I
actually is gonna touch you know
thousands tens of thousands hundreds
thousands millions billions of people
and if those those moments those
interactions they're not as thoughtful
as they could be if they create friction
in those people's lives you actually
sort of increased the amount of anxiety
and stress in the world by a huge amount
so always try to encourage designers
like take a step back you know and think
about really think deeply about their
work and realize that little decisions
they're making a design studio it does
have this effect that's going to
go out and impact you know a whole bunch
of folks and have very far-reaching
effects and that's it for me
you